we begin this half hour were the
families thanks for a remarkable rescue
last Sunday a 13 year old boy was
exploring an abandoned maintenance
building in LA's griffith park when a
wooden plank gave way he disappeared
falling some 25 feet into the city's
sewer system but the boy was saved by
dedicated rescue crews and some
remarkable new technology yesterday he
had the chance to say thanks Jamie
yuccas has the story we got the miracle
and today Jessie is safe and sound
a grateful Jessie Hernandez got an
opportunity to meet LA's mayor and
express his appreciation I'm so thankful
for everybody who was involved in my
rescue because of them I'm back with my
family the nightmare began when
Hernandez and his cousin's gained access
to this abandoned maintenance building
last Sunday I was playing and I didn't
see that it was a little piece of wood
and I stepped on it and I just fell Don
Carini Jessie plunged 25 feet into a
four foot wide sewer pipe filled with
rushing water untreated waste and toxic
gas every hour that went by is a
diminishing window of a potential
survivability I think I'm a bad parent
again more than a hundred firefighters
joined sanitation workers in a frantic
search they scoured some 2,400 feet of
pipe that has different depths of water
moving at around 15 miles per hour the
breakthrough came when they spotted
handprints on the walls of the tunnel
appears that he was trying to get out
crews used what they called batman' life
tools including a camera like this that
was put on a flotation device once they
spotted the boy they were then able to
lower a hose like this one to get him to
safety but when it comes to a life of a
person life of a kid 13-year old it
touches you hard after more than 12
hours underground rescuers finally found
Jessie nearly a mile east of where he
fell in officials tell CBS News if he
had gone any further Jessie may have
been lost in the maze of
drainage tunnels that snake below the
city it's got to be the toughest kid
I've ever seen asked to call his mom
first thing
Jessie even joked a bit as he told his
family the good news my momma life
compañía this city will now look at
demolishing the site so an accident like
this won't be repeated for CBS this
morning Saturday Jamie yuccas Los
Angeles mom I'm alive come on that's a
phone call of hair can't imagine the
Clery went through I know I know what an
amazing rescue effort by those folks
yeah really it's technology